we just got a clearer picture of who's
going to the coronation yeah and who
isn't going to the coordination Prince
Harry minus his plus one Meghan Markle
my first reaction is relief that Harry
is going to be at his father's
coronation I think it's a safe solution
given all the drama that we've seen they
are destroying us why will Megan be a
no-show well the king's coronation is
the same day as Prince Archie's fourth
birthday we're told Megan will stay in
Montecito to celebrate with Archie and
lillibet it's an excellent reason for
her to sort of wriggle out of going to
the UK to what will be for her
uncomfortable situation did you make
Kate cry no I think there's bound to be
relief
from emphasis is going to be on them
who's looking where what's going on
between them all and here's a question
with the whole world watching could we
see dueling photo ops from the same day
King Charles crowned in a lavish
ceremony versus little Archie turning
four with Mom and little sister Megan is
incredibly media savian while we have
seen birthday photos and videos released
in the past I think that she's going to
follow the same pattern of laying low
that we saw when Harry did his major
pressed her speaking of that press tour
I'm reading this book on get to Mary
could this be a chance for Harry to mend
the Royal Rift after all that drama
surrounding his Memoir I fully expect
Harry to just jet in and out for this
event I don't think he's comfortable in
the UK Charles and William they're going
to be pulled in a million different
directions it would be extraordinary to
think they would have even a minute with
Harry to even say hello let alone heal
the Royal Rift
[Music]